oui prénom monde a gravi garé mon
adolescence garrigues 6 mascarte bien
voilà un peu l'anglais
ça y est
qui signe ici et tu parles
je commence quand
j'ai un combat contre la dose incolore
inodore invisible est partout autour de
moi je respire mais mon coeur s'emballe
à son
peut expliquer sans rien ça fait quoi
l'amour la peur et les foyers les textes
c'est sa réponse
m
ce
souvent ça veut dire quoi s'asseoir
ferait chier tu ne connais pas je te
jure si on compte tout cela commence à
jouer perso ça va pas le faire tu
comprends pas ce que je te dis c'est
moche qui arrive à l'équipe de quoi tu
parles tu peux demander de trouver des
gamins et moi je vais faire avec ce
qu'ils avaient sur j'aime beaucoup c'est
simple
tout est en sursis si on relève encore
trop tout sur ton dosimètres on t'arrête
pour la saison ok moi ce que je restais
oui